i come to you today to speak of
liars
lawsuits
and laughter
the first time i heard about holocaust
denial i laughed
holocaust denial
the holocaust which has the dubious
distinction of being the best documented
genocide in the world
who could believe it didn't happen
think about it
for deniers to be right
who would have to be wrong
well first of all
the victims the survivors who have told
us their harrowing stories
who else would have to be wrong the
bystanders
the people who lived in the myriads of
towns and villages and cities on the
eastern front
who watch their neighbors be rounded up
men women children young old and be
marched to the outskirts of the town to
be shot and left dead in ditches
or the poles who lived in towns or
villages around the death camps
who watched day after day as the trains
went in full with people and came out
empty
but above all who would have to be wrong
the perpetrators
the people who say
we did it
i did it
now maybe they had a caveat
they say
i didn't have a choice i was forced to
do it
but nonetheless they said i did
think about it
in not one
war crimes trial since the end of world
war ii
has a perpetrator of any nationality
ever said it didn't happen
again they may have said i was forced
but never that it didn't happen
having thought that through i decided
denial was not going to be on my agenda
i had bigger things to worry about to
write about to research and i moved on
fast forward a little over a decade and
two senior scholars scholars of the
holocaust two most prominent historians
of the holocaust approached me and said
deborah let's have coffee we have a
research idea that we think is perfect
for you
intrigued and flattered that they came
to me with an idea and thought me worthy
of it i asked
what is it
and they said holocaust denial
and for the second time i left
holocaust denial
the flat earth folks
the elvis is alive people
i should study them
and these two guys said yeah we're
intrigued
what are they about what's their
objective
how do they manage to get people to
believe what they say
so thinking
if they thought it was worthwhile i
would take a momentary diversion
maybe a year maybe two three maybe even
four in academic terms that's momentary
um
we work very slowly um
and i would look at them
so i did i did my research and i came up
with a number of things two of which i'd
like to share with you today
one
deniers
are wolves in sheep's clothing
they are the same nazis neo-nazis you
can decide whether you want to put a neo
there or not
but when i looked at them
i didn't see
any
ss-like uniforms
swastika-like symbols on the wall
sig hile salutes
none of that
what i found instead
were people parading as respectable
academics
what did they have they had an institute
an institute for historical review
they had a journal a slick journal a
journal of historical review
one
filled with papers footnote laden papers
and they had a new name
not neo-nazis
not
anti-semites
revisionists
they said we are revisionists we are out
to do one thing to revise mistakes in
history
but all you had to do was go one inch
below the surface
and what did you find there
the same adulation of hitler praise of
the third reich
anti-semitism racism prejudice
this is what intrigued me
it was anti-semitism racism prejudice
parading
as rational discourse
the other thing i found many of us have
been taught to think there are facts in
their opinions after studying deniers i
think differently
there are facts
there are opinions
and they're lies
and what deniers want to do
is take their lies
dress them up as opinions maybe edgy
opinions maybe sort of out of the box
opinions but then if their opinions they
should be part of the conversation
and then they encroach on the facts
i published my work the book was
published denying the holocaust the
growing assault on truth and memory came
out in many different countries
including here in penguin uk and i was
done with those folks and ready to move
on
then
came the letter from penguin uk
and for the third time i laughed
mistakenly
i opened the letter
and it informed me that david irving was
bringing a libel suit against me in the
united kingdom for calling him a
holocaust denier
david irving's suing me
who was david irving david irving was a
writer of historical works most of them
about world war ii and virtually all of
those works
took the position that
the nazis were really not so bad
and the allies were really not so good
and the jews whatever happened to them
they sort of deserved it
he knew the documents he knew the facts
but he somehow twisted them to get this
opinion
he hadn't always been a holocaust denier
but in the late 80s he embraced it with
great vigor
the reason i left also was this was a
man
who not only was a holocaust denier but
seemed quite proud of it
here was a man and i quote who said i'm
going to sink the battleship auschwitz
here was a man who pointed to the number
tattooed on a survivor's arm and said
how much money have you made from having
that number tattooed on your arm
here was a man who said
more people died and sent her to
kennedy's car chappaquiddick then died
in gas chambers at auschwitz that's an
american reference but you can look it
up
this was not a man who seemed at all
ashamed or reticent about being a
holocaust denier
now lots of my academic colleagues
counseled me
ah deborah just ignore it when i
explained you can't just ignore a libel
suit they said who's gonna believe him
anyway
but here was the problem british law
put the onus put the burden of proof on
me
to prove the truth of what i said
in contrast as it would have been in the
united states and in many other
countries on him to prove the falsehood
what did that mean that meant if i
didn't fight
he would win by default
and if he won by default he could then
legitimately say my david irving version
of the holocaust is a legitimate version
deborah lipster was found to have
libeled me when she called me a
holocaust denier ipso facto i david
irving i'm not a holocaust denier and
what is that version
there was no plan to murder the jews
there were no gas chambers there were no
mass shootings hitler had nothing to do
with any suffering that went on and the
jews have made this all up
to get money from germany and to get a
state and they've done it with the aid
and obedience of the allies they've
planted the documents and planted the
evidence i couldn't let that stand
and ever face a survivor
or a child of survivors i couldn't let
that stand
and consider myself a responsible
historian
so we fought
and for those of you who haven't seen
denial his spoiler alert
we won
the judge
found david irving
to be
a
liar a racist an anti-semite his view of
history was tendacious he lied he
distorted and most importantly
he did it deliberately we showed a
pattern in over 25 different major
instances not small things many of us in
this audience write books are writing
books we always make mistakes that's why
we're glad to have second editions
correct the mistakes
but these always moved in the same
direction
blame
the jews exonerate the nazis
but how did we win
what we did is follow his footnotes back
to his sources
and what did we find not in most cases
and not in the preponderance of cases
but in every single instance where he
made some reference to the holocaust
that his supposed evidence was distorted
half truth
date changed sequence changed
someone put in a meeting who wasn't
there in other words he didn't have the
evidence his evidence didn't prove it
we didn't prove
what happened
we proved that what he said happened and
by extension all deniers because he
either quotes them or they get their
arguments from him
is not true they what they claim they
don't have the evidence to prove it
so why is my
story more than just the story of a
quirky long six-year difficult lawsuit
an american professor being declared
being dragged into a courtroom by a man
that the court declared in its judgment
was a neo-nazi polemicist what message
does it have
i think in the context of the question
of truth it has a very significant
message
because today
as we well know
truth and facts are under assault
social media for all the gifts it has
given us has also allowed the difference
between facts established facts
and
lies to be flattened
third of all
extremism
it's per you may not see
ku klux klan robes you may not see
burning crosses you may not even hear
outright white supremacist language it
may go by names alt-right national
fronts pick your names but underneath
it's that same extremism that i found in
holocaust denial parading as rational
discourse
we live in an age
where truth is on the defensive i'm
reminded of a new yorker cartoon a quiz
show recently appeared in the new yorker
where the host of the quiz show is
saying to one of the contestants yes
ma'am you had the right answer
but your opponent yelled more loudly
than you did so he gets the point
what can we do
first of all
we cannot be beguiled by rational
appearances we've got to look underneath
and we will find there the extremism
second of all
we must understand
that truth
is not
relative
number three
we must go on the offensive not the
defensive
when someone makes an outrageous claim
even though they may hold one of the
highest offices in the land if not the
world
we must say to them where's the proof
where's the evidence
we must hold their feet to the fire we
must not treat it as if their lies are
the same as the facts
and as i said earlier truth is not
relative
many of us have grown up in the world of
the academy in enlightened liberal
thought where we're taught everything is
open to debate
but that's not the case
there are certain things that are true
there are indisputable facts
objective truths
galileo taught it to us
centuries ago
even after being forced to recant by the
vatican that the earth moved around the
sun
he came out and what is he reported to
have said
and yet
it still
moves
the earth is not flat
the climate is changing
elvis is not alive
and most importantly
truth
and fact
are under assault
the job ahead of us the task ahead of us
the challenge ahead of us is great
the time to fight is short
we must act
now
later
will be
too late
thank you very much